punishing us sanctions will be
re-imposed on Iran starting next week as
part of President Trump's decision to
pull out of the Iran nuclear deal that
agreement in 2015 led to the release of
several Americans being held by Iran but
there are currently at least three more
detained Americans live Elizabeth Palmer
is in the capital city of Tehran with
what the new sanctions mean for those
still being held good morning the three
Americans detained here were all
arrested in 2015 or 16 on vague charges
of either collaborating with or spying
for the United States
thirty-eight-year-old CUA Hwang is a
Princeton graduate student who is doing
research here he's serving a ten year
sentence in Tehran's grim Avene prison
eighty two-year-old Bakr namazi was an
amine tube he's now critically sick
under house arrest his son siamak a
businessman is also serving a ten-year
sentence in a beam we spoke with Jared
Ganser washington-based lawyer who acts
for the Namas 'is there needs to be a
private dialogue between both
governments to find on humanitarian
basis a way to to do some kind of a
prisoner swap iran's Foreign Minister
told me he was pushing for a so-called
humanitarian solution to and hinted at a
prisoner exchange but it's not going to
happen anytime soon meanwhile it's
interesting to note that we haven't
heard the kind of blistering rhetoric
against the United States with these
coming sanctions that we've heard in the
past instead Iran is portraying itself
as a country that stuck to the nuclear
deal and is simply being bullied by
America Gayle Elizabeth Palmer in Tehran
thank you